بسم الله
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل كل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى في كتابه الكريم
وما خلقت الجن والانس الا ليعبدون
ما اريد منهم من رزق وما اريد ان يطعمونه
ان الله هو الرزاق
ذو القوه المتين
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏As a matter of humanity
has struggled in the darkness stuming
around
those of the human race who
noting
theations andw
the answer to this question
‏What is that? Why do we ex
why do we exha
benited harmed by anything or don't why
do we ex? What is our purose? Who are
we? Why are we here? Where did we come?
‏and
question
like
common knowledge to the one
is blessed with the quر
but without thew to these question
the human being will quite literally
selfdestruct
‏to much
and
can only be filled by
to difficult
to
without anwers
الله سبحانه وتالى hew for us these
question he tells us in theosinges
‏and not
kind and
except so that they may me
I do not need them
to give me anything do I need them to
provide for me or feed me indeed Allah
he is the one who sustain
is the one who
سبحانه وتالى
الله
and
the benit and
‏are
so
and
alone without any partnership
Allah in the way that Allah has
commanded andlated in the way that he
hased
الامام مسلم رحمه الله
حديث
‏translated as a collection of holy
narration what is holy about them
this is a narration in which the
propetai
wasates
to us that himself said but it's not
part of the quر the quر is all the words
of all
and
احاديث قدسيه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ابوذر الغفاري
رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم ساب قال الله عز وجل
اني حرمت الظلم على نفسي
وجعلته بينكم محرما فلا تظالموا
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏said
indeed
I have made
oppression
prohibited upon my own s
and in turn have made oppression
and transgression prohibited upon you
all so do not oppress one another do not
transgress
against one
الله
يا عبادي
كلكم
جائع الا من اطعمته
فاستطعموني
اطعمكم
each and
you
يا عبادي
كلكم عار الا من كسوته
فاستكسوني
اكسكم
‏My slaves, each and every of you is
naked
except for those
soek from me and I shall youهدكم
‏myg
l
except for those i gu so seek gu
يا عباديكم
يا عبادي انكم
تخطئون بالليل والنهار
وانا اغفر الذنوب جميعا فاستغفروني
اغفر لكم
and for all sinek
forgiveness and shall for
يا عبادي
لو ان اولكم
واخركم
وانسكم
وجنكم
كانوا على اتقى قلب رجل منكم ما زاد ذلك
في ملك شيئا
‏Lord continues to say my slaves, my
servants, my creation, if all of you,
the first of you and the last of you,
the gin of you and the human of you, all
have the heart of the most rightous man
among you, this would not increase me in
the least.
This would not increase me in the least.
يا عبادي لو ان اولكم
واخركم
وانسكم وجنكم
كانوا على افجر قلب رجل منكم ما نقص ذلك
من ملك شيئا
[Silence]
‏am
‏harble
يا عبادي
لو ان اولكم
واخركم
وانسكم
وجنكم
قاموا في صعيد واحد فسالوني
فاعطيت كل واحد مساله
ما نقص ذلك مما عندي الا كما ينقص المخيط
اذا ادخل البحر
‏and of you the
first of you and the last of you all on
one
and all asked me for everything they
could
desire
and I in turn gave each and every one of
you everything he asked
this would not diminish my dominion
‏any
tak
يا عبادي
انما هي اعمالكم
احصيها لكم ثم اوفيكم اياها
فمن وجد خيرا فليحمد الله
ومن وجد غير ذلك فلا يلومن الا نفسه
preserve
andal
and
recomense you for it is yours which i
shall calculate
‏upon such
whoever
receives good
he is to than and praise Allah for that
good
and whoever receives other than good
whoever judg ends badly then he has no
one to blame but his own for
الله سبحانه وتالى
are
[Arabic recitation]
our
we increasingly
godless and materialistic
society today
where our children are being t these sil
of confidence and selfestem
and we as musl don't believe in
الله رب العالمين
[Silence]
اللهمين
‏tocri
and all in your life to Allah
and whenever you need or feel
that you cann you turn to Allah it is
a mountain of weight has been
lifted off of your shoulders
الله سبحانه وى
[Silence]
الله
سبحانه وتالى
رين
[Silence]
وى
‏and your
love before you can love other
you have in your and man
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ولا تكلني الى نفسي طرفه عين ابداع
اللهink
[Silence]
have
you confidence
‏have
that is only that can provide them with
strength with identity with audacity
with hope it is not found in your we as
human beings are naturally in the
deficit we are naked except for those
among
‏are
we are except for those among us guided
we are ignorant except for those among
us
everything that is good in your life has
come to you from and alone you nothing
to do with that الله سبحانه
‏any
praises us
anyone of us any trait of
واصبر وماك الا بالله
الله
سبحانه وى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وما بكم من نعمه فمن الله
ليس من نفسك ليس من علمك ليس من قوتك ولا
حولك بل علمنا رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان اذا شرب احدنا شربه او اكل اكله
ان يقول الحمد لله الذي اطعمني هذا وسقاني
من غير حول مني ولا قوه
بل نادى المنادي للصلاه حي على الصلاه حي
على الفلاح لقننا رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
وان هذه الثقه بالنفس والايمان
بالنفس وللاسف
اصحاب بنو جلدتنا
من يتكلمون بلغتنا
في اقصاء المشرق اصبحوا يدندنون
بهذه ويقولون بما يقوله اعداء الله ليس
هذا ايماننا ولا عقيدتنا
نحن نؤمن بالله ونحمد الله فمن وجد خيرا
فليحمد الله ومن وجد غير ذلك فلا يلومن
الا نفسه هكذا قال ربنا وما بكم من نعمه
من الله وما بكم من نعمه فمن الله وان
تعدوا نعمه الله لا تحصوها
هكذا الله سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الحمد لله than
‏any
الله tells us there is notle
in your livescept
come to you Allah tells us and if you to
attemp toate bless upon you you would
never be able to do
‏is not ourle
ourle
is
given us and so prop teaches us
himself said so upon judg when you stand
before and you are judged if youce good
than good because each of us is naked
except for
‏each is for those
each of us is ignorant except for those
guided and
whoever encounters or receives bad upon
such judg he is to blame none other than
his own you had all the tools you had
all the time you had all the faul
gave
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اقول ما تسمعون استغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان
محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل على محمد وعلى
ال محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال
ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد اللهم بارك على
محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم
وعلى ال ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد
مجيد اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وكفر عنا
سيئاتنا وتوفنا مع الابرار ربنا واتنا ما
وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد عاد اللهم ربنا اننا
نسالك فعل الخيرات وترك المنكرات وحب
المساكين وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب
علينا واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك
غير مفتونين اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من جهد
البلاء ودرك الشقاء وسوء القضاء وشماته
الاعداء اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء ومرافقه الانبياء والنصر
على الاعداء يا سميع الدعاء يا ذا المن
والعطاء اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من الغلا
والزنا والربا والزلازل والمحن والفتن ما
ظهر منها وما بطن اللهم اجعل القران ربيع
قلوبنا ونور صدورنا وجلاء احزاننا وذهاب
همومنا اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين وافضح النفاق
والمنافقين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في
غزه وفلسطين وفي السودان وفي لبنان وفي
سوريا وفي كشمير وفي الشيشان اللهم
واخواننا كذلك المجاهدين المطهدين في
ايران اللهم انصرهم على عدوهم اللهم
انصرهم على عدوهم واجعلهم على عدوهم
ظاهرين قاهرين منصورين اللهم عليك بهذا
الكيان الصهيون اللعيم اللهم انه قد عا في
الارض فسادا وانك لبالمرصاد اللهم ارنا
فيهم عجائب قدرتك اللهم زلزل اركانهم وصدع
بنيانهم واقتل اجنادهم اللهم اضرب عليهم
الذل والهوان والصغار حيث حلوا اللهم
واجعل قتلاهم في النيران اللهم امين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد ‏Yeah.